et des idées courageuse des mots qui
comptent
là elle en soi vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui une gauche extrêmement tous
les témoins de notre époque sont dans la
grande interview
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et reporters sur le terrain tout
de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 25 février 20
départements du nord de l'ile-de-france
de l'est et du sud est placé sous
surveillance renforcé l'exécutif se
donne une semaine pour décider
d'éventuelles mesures supplémentaires
dans ces territoires comme un
confinement le week end la vaccination
anti qu'ovide se poursuit sa progression
chez les plus fragiles pourrait
permettre une réduction des restrictions
sanitaires d'ici le mois de juin pour
plus le premier ministre israël renforce
encore un peu plus son arsenal
législatif face au co vide
le pays vient d'adopter une loi
permettant de communiquer l'identité des
personnes non vaccinées provoquant ainsi
la colère de l'opposition côté politique
benyamin netanyahou s'est entretenu avec
joe biden au téléphone elle souhaiterait
que les etats-unis maintiennent leurs
sanctions contre les membres de la cour
pénale internationale afin de limiter la
probabilité d'une enquête sur des crimes
de guerre commis à gaza et en
cisjordanie en 2014
[Musique]
le président arménien appel à la retenue
et au bon sens il va travailler des
mesures d'urgence pour désamorcer la
crise en arménie ce matin l'état-major
de l'armée appelé à la démission du
premier ministre nikol pashinian qui
dort tous qui en retour a dénoncé une
tentative de coup d'état militaire les
deux camps sont descendus dans la rues
de la capitale
[Musique]
le premier ministre jean castex et
olivier ferrandes ont tenu tout à
l'heure leur traditionnelle conférence
de presse sur la situation sanitaire en
france des départements sont surveillés
comme le lait sur le feu cette semaine
pour plus de précisions nous retrouvons
tout de suite nadège abderrazak en
direct de l'avenue de ségur
bonsoir nadège alors que doit-on retenir
de cette prise de parole de jean castex
et d'olivier veyrat
nous avons réussi à réduire la
propagation du coc u19 mais pas celle
des variants les propos sont signés
d'olivier ferrand la ministre de la
santé a été accompagné de jean castex
premier ministre aujourd'hui pour son
point hebdomadaire sur la crise
sanitaire alors après nice et dunkerque
un ouf a été instauré un confinement le
week end on s'attendait à ce que la
mesure soit appliquée dans d'autres
départements où la situation est tout
aussi critique mais ça n'a pas été le
cas néanmoins vingt départements sont
désormais sous surveillance renforcée en
ile-de-france dans les hautes france en
provence alpes côte d'azur dans le rôle
la drôme la moselle en meurthe et
moselle et en eure et loir et si la
situation ne s'améliore pas d'ici une
semaine les mesures seront renforcés
pour le week end du 6 mars prévient jean
castex et on pourra donc éventuellement
reparler de confinement les week-ends de
c'est en quelques sortes un sursis que
donne le premier ministre
j'ai demandé aux préfets des
départements concernés d'engager des
concertations avec les élus en vue
d'inviter sans attendre tous les
habitants à la plus grande vigilance et
d'envisager dans tout ou partie de ce
territoire des mesures de freinage
proches de celles mises en place à nice
et dunkerque
nous ferons un point au terme de ces
concertations la semaine prochaine et
nous déciderons alors si et seulement si
la situation continue à se dégrader
nous prendrons des mesures renforcées
qui entreront en vigueur à compter du
week-end du 6 mars et la neige une
situation sanitaire qui se dégradent
donc d'après le gouvernement qui annonce
le chiffre de
trente mille 4 contamination enregistrés
hier
absolument et c'est un record depuis le
mois de novembre c'est malgré tout un
chiffre qu'il faut relativiser pourquoi
et bien parce que lundi seuls 4000 cas
de contamination ont été comptabilisés
donc sur ses 30000 qu'a annoncé hier il
s'agit plutôt d'un retard d'un
rattrapage de comptabilité sur plusieurs
jours quoiqu'il en soit le virus est
toujours présent et pour le faire
reculer la vaccination semble être la
seule méthode efficace selon le
gouvernement la campagne de vaccination
suit son cours et est bien elle se l
olivier ferrand sont félicités coûté si
vous êtes âgé de 75 ans et plus et que
vous vivez chez vous et bien vous pouvez
prendre rendez vous sur internet sur le
site sante.gouv.fr ou par le numéro vert
national ou en appelant directement le
centre le plus proche de chez vous il y
en a mille deux cents sur toute la
france mais prendre rendez vous pour
vous faire vacciner avec ce qu'on
appelle les vaccins à arn messager nous
espérons avoir terminé la vaccination de
toutes les personnes âgées volontaires
d'ici à la fin du mois de mars
permettant donc ensuite d'ouvrir la
vaccination aux 65 ans et plus si vous
êtes plus jeunes voire beaucoup plus
jeunes mais que vous figurer sur une
liste de personnes qui sont atteintes de
maladie particulièrement grave et qui
fait que vous êtes très fragile aux
risques du virus vous pouvez aussi vous
faire vacciner en centre de vaccination
avec une prescription médicale avec les
vaccins kaiser et modern art et sachez
qu'à partir d'aujourd'hui les médecins
généralistes ont la possibilité de
vacciner leurs patients âgés de 50 à 64
ans préside présentant des comorbidités
donc susceptibles de développer une
forme grave de la maladie
ah voilà donc un qui pourrait donner un
coup de boost à cette campagne de
vaccination qui prend son temps
il faut savoir que pour l'heure seuls
deux millions six cent mille français
ont reçu la première dose du vaccin
merci l adage abderrazak en direct de
l'avenue de ségur et gouvernement qui
poursuit donc sa stratégie territoriale
il soit être réactif aux premiers signes
de reprise avec des actions plus ciblées
afin de
c'est le temps la vaccination de
produire ses effets impossible
d'envisager à ce jour des mesures de
relâchement pour en parler place à notre
décryptage ce soir avec nos invités et
nous sommes en direct avec gilbert
collard député européen est reine
cyrille isaac sibille médecin député
modem 12e circonscription du rhône
enfin loïc prud'hommes député la france
insoumise troisième circonscription de
gironde bonsoir messieurs merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france donc à
retenir ce soir évidemment 20
départements qui ont été placés sous
surveillance renforcée en raison d'une
circulation accrue de l'épidémie 1 qui
bat malheureusement des records à
nouveau on pourrait faire l'objet de
mesures de confinement 1 nous par
exemple ile de france et d'autres
régions la vue à partir du week-end du 6
mars
en clair ça nous pend au nez cyrille
isaac sibille j'ai entendu comme vous et
vivement la conférence de presse dupré
milices et demi la santé non je pense
que quand koné puis les bus ce qu'il
faut ce virus on a beaucoup on
s'attendre mammouth surprises parfois
par rapport à lui
je pense que notre rôle en tout cas le
rôle du gouvernement c'est d'anticiper
de survie courbe d'anticiper et prendre
les bonnes mesures
jusqu'à maintenant effectivement on y
avait plein de la santé ils prennent de
l'économie en a eu aussi le problème du
manque de la santé mentale et de l'état
psychologique de nos concitoyens il faut
tenir compte de cette propriétaire et
donc on anticipe en même temps ce qui
est très important c'est qu'on fait il
concertation territoriale
c'est important d'aller via les élus
locaux verts les représentants des
départements pour comprendre ce qui se
passe et avoir une réponse adaptée et en
accord avec eux alors loïc prénomme
justement cette concertation
territoriale ça fait un sacré bout de
temps que les élus locaux la demande
depuis d'ailleurs le début de l'épidémie
enfin
ernement a compris a entendu l'appel des
régions parce que jean castex avait
l'air de dire que ça ne date pas d'hier
mais enfin c'est quand même la première
fois que les élus locaux sont concertés
à ce point et qu'en tous cas les
décisions au lieu localement c'est une
bonne chose
je sais pas s'il faut se réjouir ou pas
mais c'est surtout a dit jean castex et
qu'il continuait de surveiller et
surveille le concept mais ma question
assez quand est ce qu il agi parce que
effectivement la question des
concertations avec les élus territoriaux
elle a surtout à un autre et c'est celui
du contrôle des flux de population et on
a vu la situation de 10 ce qui était
assez révélatrice où il ya eu des
concertations pour régler une ciste un
problème qui n'a pas été réglé en amont
à savoir le contrôle des flux notamment
entre ans et le fait de laisser rentrer
et eva rien parce qu'il veut au col
aucun contrôle efficace il demande de
test pc avant de rentrer sur le
territoire national mais ça évoqué le
cas au volant a vu ali ce que l'on a vu
à dunkerque et que l'on commence à voir
maintenant sur vingt départements où la
seule réponse du gouvernement essaie
dédiant on va surveiller
on va surveiller la progression des
variables et le problème c'est qu'ils
ont laissé ces variants rentrer
massivement sur le territoire et que
maintenant tout semble hors de contrôle
alors vous pouvez conserver autant
d'élus locaux que vous voulez c'est vrai
que ça sera toujours mieux que de ne pas
le faire vu j'allais dire le manque de
l'inconséquence de gouvernement je pense
que les locaux seront d'un apport plutôt
positif mais ça ne réglera pas tout ce
qui n'a pas été fait en amont et
notamment la question aussi de la
gestion des quantités de vaccins nous
parliez tout à l'heure de enfin
l'apparition du vaccin astrazeneca chez
le médecin généraliste en termes de
quantité c'est une catastrophe absolue
un flacons de dix doses par médecin
généraliste
je pense que les médecins vont apprécier
de penser qu'ils n'ont dans leur carnet
d adresses que 10 personnes
potentiellement vaccinable c'est juste
une plaisanterie en fait c'est pas comme
ça qu'on peut avancer rapidement sur la
vaccination nous ça sent l'impréparation
d'improvisation reviendra évidemment sur
la campagne de vaccination
gilbert collard il faut tout faire pour
retarder un confinement la stratégie du
gouvernement est très clair
vous êtes satisfait on peut pas être
satisfait dans dans l'état de situation
pandémique dont se trouveront peut être
qu'en vois c'est que préoccupé parce que
aucune solution n'est la bonne dans la
mesure où le virus et ses variantes sont
méchamment mauvais ce que je constate
c'est que on tient un discours qui est
pulvérisé de l'intérieur parce qu'il est
contradictoire et ça c'est très mauvais
on nous dit que on maîtrise le virus les
camps de maîtrise plus les variants on
n'est pas franchement pour des pour des
blaireaux vrai bon on savait depuis des
semaines et des semaines et des semaines
que les les variants était là et que ce
se greffait sur le sur le virus toute
cette mobilité des variants bon
aujourd'hui on nous dit que 20
départements sauf erreur de ma part sont
sous surveillance renforcée
ça veut dire quoi ça ça veut dire que le
gouvernement est atteint de
procrastination
il n'arrive pas à prendre de décision il
sait très bien que dans quelques jours
il va devoir confiné mais comme il a
peur d'une manière légitime du reste de
la manière dont ce confinement
qui est dû au fait essentiellement on
n'a pas le lait place nécessaire de
réanimation parce que de nombreux lieux
ont été supprimés non notamment en
notamment nice et à l'époque je crois
que monsieur castex avaient des
responsabilités dans ce domaine on
peaufine voilà si on avait l'espace
médical sont lavés les lits de
réanimation serait pas obligé de prendre
toutes ces mesures mais comme on a peur
des réactions populaires liés à la
souffrance du confinement ont fait
presque des prêts anesthésie confine à
thouars chaque fois c'est à dire que on
nous laisse entendre qu'on va peut-être
mais qu'on fera tout ce qu'on peut pour
ne pas faire mais qu'on va devoir faire
en même temps perdre du temps alors s'il
faut confiné ils le savent à l'instant
où je parle
ils n'ont pas besoin de quatre cinq six
jours de plus et tout ce jeu dialectique
de communication nous mêmes ne
préoccupent les inquiète voilà je je ne
jette la pierre à personne parce que le
moment est difficile et que ce serait
d'une prétention inouïe que de vouloir
détenir ici la vérité mais du point de
vue si vous voulez de ce qui est de ce
qui est perçu de ce qui est de scier
vécu ce n'est pas très bon en ce qui
concerne les vaccins par exemple
monsieur fisher avec avait avait
violemment critiqué le vaccin
astrazeneca est aujourd'hui ici devient
une espèce d' affiches publicitaires
parlante lors de la conférence de presse
comment comprendre la genèse comment
comprendre que entre le entre le moment
où il avait déconseillé aux soignants de
moselle de prendre ce vaccin est
maintenant les choses ont changé bon
péter eu des études que j'ignore j'en
sais rien mais tout cela fait l'effet
d'une espèce de deux déambulations
erratique voilà essais et c'est vraiment
très très angoissant
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire d'autre on a
le sentiment que
les maîtriser rien n'est contrôlé et
surtout via les 10 essentiellement voilà
c'est préoccupant c'est surtout qu'on
parle tous de re confinement y compris
nous les journalistes
voilà comme si c'était un risque
potentiel on oublie peut-être qu'on est
confiné partiellement depuis quand même
fin octobre je vous le rappelle en
messieurs qu'on va plus au restaurant
qu'on ne sort plus le soir qu'on ne va
plus au musée plus au cinéma on a
peut-être le droit d'aller travailler et
éventuellement d'aller faire les courses
mais c'est tout il ya une forme voilà de
résignation vous le sentez comme ça loïc
prud'hommes des de la part des français
ou alors on se dit qu un confinement
strict ce serait peut-être encore pire
j'ai pas de résignation je pense que il
ya effectivement de l'incompréhension
parce que tout ça est largement
improvisé il ya aussi une grande attente
sur ces questions de vaccination et et
que le gouvernement n'est pas en mesure
aujourd'hui d'y répondre puisque kim ans
déjà les gens de 8 75 ans n'ont pas de
place se faire vacciner je vous l'assuré
ainsi environ c'est la même chose et je
le vis direct le nombre pour mes proches
c'est de se faire vacciner et dès cette
année d'un constat d'échec aussi sur
cette question d'un provisionnement où
il ya des contrats opa qui ont des
passés avec l'union européenne et qui
aboutissent aujourd'hui à ce fiasco
complet
on a aussi cette question qui a été
évoqué que en fait tout ça et c'est
pourquoi parce qu'on a des hôpitaux qui
sont dans tension et c'est aussi un
échec du gouvernement qui a su trouver 5
milliards pour renflouer
air france klm les mêmes qui a pas
trouvé le premier euro pour renforcer
notre système hospitalier
donc non les français sont pas résignés
ils sont juste
débailly de voir à quel point on peut on
peut après un an continue à improviser
alors que l'on devrait avoir un
gouvernement qui agit et ça c'est quand
même juste incroyable que aujourd'hui on
évoque une action que on attend de voir
dans cinq jours d'observer le de
surveiller de manière à renforcer ici ou
là mais rien n'est fait rien n'est fait
pour demander une licence d'office pour
la production des vaccins en nombre
alors que ça ça pourrait vraiment vous
sortir d'un mauvais pas rien de rien
n'est fait en fait pour aider les
français à avoir le bout du tunnel et
c'est surtout ça qui le vénère le
gouvernement à chaque fois je sais pas
si vous avez remarqué à chaque
conférence de presse qu'on suit
attentivement le jeune y avait un petit
moment de satisfaction quand même et
défend son bilan c'est bien normal
je vous propose d'écouter jean castex
qui se dit on a bien fait de ne pas
confiner la dernière fois écouté avec le
président de la république nous avons
souhaité le mois dernier nous donner
tous les moyens d'éviter un nouveau
confinement que nous avions envisagé fin
janvier sur la base de projections qui
nous prédisaient une dégradation rapide
et brutale de la situation
cette décision s'est avérée la bonne
nous a permis de gagner du temps or ce
temps est précieux car chaque jour nous
avons un peu plus de personnes vaccinées
on appris après quand même que jean
castex a pas toujours été d'accord avec
emmanuel macron sur le point de vue du
confinement bref mais là je m'adresse au
docteur pas seulement aux députés en
syrie disait que sybille on comprends
pas bien cette idée de rendre confine
pas donc on gagne du temps pour vacciner
on a vu les exemples au royaume uni en
israël la n'empêchait pas l'autre il y
avait des restrictions déconfinement en
israël et au royaume uni et on continuer
à vacciner massivement est ce que vous
comprenez cet argument du premier
ministre koichi médecin il ya trois
choses premièrement il ya les gestes
barrières on a on a trois armes
on a les gestes barrières on a le
confinement
on a le vaccin moi je suis un petit peu
surpris par mes contradicteurs camp
quand il parle filmant des variants
quand j'entendis de prud'hommes qui
bisimwa il faudrait confier plus ils
faillirent allait s'attaquer aux
variables mais qu'est ce que vous
souhaitez le gouvernement une politique
plus autoritaire on a eu ce débat
l'assemblée nationale c'est tout je
pense que important et c'est ce que fait
le gouvernement
le gouvernement il anticipe donc
immigrés sont bio voilà les chiffres qui
montrent qu'on peut être amené à prendre
telle décision pour prendre des
décisions on a beaucoup reproché au
gouvernement de ne pas avoir une
approche territoriale donc là il va
consulter les vaccins comme la règle
comme l'a répété olivier rang on est à
flux tendu chaque fois qu'on a des doses
de vaccin ou les répercute de manière
transparente sur l'ensemble de la
population
vous parlez timo de la baratte en
pharmacie tic il faut quand même
rappeler ici à ses extrémités à moi j'ai
su médecin en un an on est arrivé à
fabriquer des médecins plusieurs types
de vaccins et on est et on est capable
de faire cette vaccination très large de
la population
chose qui n'a jamais été fait alors
j'entends bien que peu de critiques et
je trouve que ce gouvernement
qu'est ce qu'il fait il anticipe il dit
grosso modo les chiffes que montrer donc
on peut profiter pour tignes les gestes
barrières on continue la vaccination est
idiot et donc je je pense que c'est là
c'est vraiment la laddh la nabe eu la
bonne attitude donc bien évidemment gym
l'issue mais samedi le ces virus nous a
posé beaucoup de problèmes été surprise
et chaque fois qu'on a une solution
on a un problème face à ses missions ça
s'est passé lors des masques ça s'est
passé lors des tests mam nay et les
vaccins on progresse en avance et je
trouve que lorsqu'on lorsqu'on se
compare par rapport
on a les derniers chiffres par rapport
aux derniers ceo au peuple et aux états
européens on est
la france le pays qui fascine le mieux
c'est à dire qu'il va cibler gens qui
sont plus fragiles donc au dessus de 75
ans qui parle car nos voisins on est le
pays on a au contraire l'auteur on va on
fait de la vaccination le rappelle donc
je pense que quelqu'un est ce que fait
le gouvernement ils l'anticipent il
rappelle qu il y 3 via les gestes
barrière via la vaccination est un
confinement si on n'arrive pas à juguler
suffisamment la montée du virus
et puis en même temps il ya six courses
contre est bien tard donnez-moi 200 m3
alors j'essaye de distribuer la parole
pardonnez-moi loïc prud'hommes
d'ailleurs gilbert collard alors vous
avez dû malheureusement cyrille isaac
sybille est convaincre assure le sur ce
point de la vaccination
loïc prénomme vous voyez lever les yeux
au ciel oui si je disais que je voulais
plus de confinement en confirmant sur
une plus stricte pas du tout je pointe
et l'absence de contrôle de par des
tests sur les flux entrant saint denis
depuis des mois je le dis mais quand on
laisse les flux aller et venir
effectivement les variants et le vaccin
et le virus se répand alors après les
éléments de langage d'autosatisfaction
de monsieur et isaac sibille c'est
personne n'y croit on a bien vu que
c'est une catastrophe absolue l'on n'a
pas les vaccins en banque
il est d'abord accord les produits mais
on attend toujours la liste des licences
d'office pour coup tout le monde puisse
en profiter
on revient que les pays riches qui
vaccine les pays pauvres n'ont pas accès
aux vaccins et ont saisi d'une épidémie
mondiale et donc si on n'a pas à me
répondre et mondial ont fait c'est comme
si on faisait rien donc c'est assez
étonnant
d'avoir un déni de la réalité à la
commission de 10 mois je vous coupe
aussi pour distribuer la parole mais on
va écouter jean castex qui fait une
petite allusion qui en dit long sur
peut-être nos difficultés quant à la
vaccination écouter d'ici fin mars
les deux tiers des personnes de plus de
75 ans seront vaccinés et nous ouvrirons
début avril la vaccination aux plus de
65 ans pour autant nous dépendons de la
fabrication et de la livraison des doses
commandées par l'union européenne et il
faudra nous armer de patience
il n'en reste pas moins qu'à la mi-mai
la totalité des personnes de plus de 50
ans se seront vus proposer une première
injection
gilbert collard alors on sent une voie
là soit un début d'aveu soit et bien
c'est pas de notre faute
il faut s'armer de patience et la faute
à l'europe qu'est ce que répond le
député européen vous êtes le député
européen répond que c'est l'échec
monumental de de l'union européenne qui
atteint qui a passé des contrats d'une
manière absolument pas transparents les
députés n'ont quasiment pas pu voir les
contrats il était quand seul et donc on
n'avait pas la possibilité de les lire
il y avait quand on y avaient accès une
surveillance bondon tout cela sans sent
mauvais vraiment c est on est on le voit
dans ce cas dit monsieur castex
complètement dépendant de la delà de la
production qu'on ne contrôle pas qu'on
ne maîtrise pas l'or moi je comprends
que que comprend on utilise des éléments
de langage pour défendre une politique
mais là on est dans la santé on est dans
la vie dans la survie dans la mort
donc on n'a pas le droit aux éléments de
langage on n'a pas le droit
les vaccins manque c'est un mensonge de
dire le contraire
on ne peut pas vacciner tout le monde
est là la certitude d'avoir tout lé
vaccin n'existe même pas en ce qui
concerne astra on nous disait que
c'était pas un bon vaccin
on nous dit maintenant parce qu'il vient
combler la pénurie que c'est
car ça pour les gens entendent ils
enregistrent ce qui se dit de la même
manière les centres de vaccination qui
devait être démultipliée ne le sont pas
de la même manière que les lits
d'hôpitaux qui devait être démultipliée
ne l'ont pas été que dis-je démultiplier
comble et comblée en déficit ne l'ont
pas été bon il ya une situation
erratique erratique et un gouvernement
qui gagne du temps alors la question
qu'il faudra se poser un jour ou l'autre
ils gagnent du temps sur quoi sur la
politique sur la santé sur l'économie
sur l'état psychique des français ce
gain de temps qui valent payer au bout
du compte il faut voir ce qui se cache
derrière les mots et il faut pas fuir
devant la situation
je crois que aucun aucun d'entre nous
n'a le droit de faire de la politique là
parce que c'est une affaire de santé la
réalité est que les vaccins on en a pas
suffisamment ils sont pas livrés
rappelez-vous le problème des doses de
la 6ème d'ordre des complications
extraordinaire que ça a créé
rappelez vous des problèmes de
l'acheminement des vaccins le le
problème de la réserve frigorifique
toutes les questions qui ont été posées
que les gens ont des dettes dont on
voudrait appeler ce gouvernement à ne
pas gagner du temps mais à gagner des
vies à gagner des vies ça serait quand
même autre chose un autre programme
voilà ce qui me préoccupe et encore une
fois je peux comprendre quand on est
dans un dans un groupe dont descendent
avec les armes du langage que l'on peut
vous fournir mais là on est plus dans le
domaine
de la discussion politique 1 on est dans
le domaine de la de la vie et de la mort
et puis il peut taper à votre teint
comme la mienne
donc faisons pas trop les malins n'ont
plus cédé à casser vite puisque vous
êtes interpellé par gilbert collard je
vous demande quelles réponses rapides
parce qu'on va aller c'est le mot de la
fin aussi à halloween club très
rapidement face une crise comme ça
justement nicolas reeves ou penseurs
politiques vous propos ne sont que
politique
quelque part j'attendrai de vous au ce
cirque tout ce qui m'a poussé sap toucy
poudre il pour répondre aux français au
lieu d'agiter les peurs
chaque fois vous revenez sur astra astra
le professeur fisher l'état leur astre à
gilly est un bon vaccin dit lost hobo
vaccin n'essayez pas de produire de
faire la politique en disant bas-côté
voilà on a des doutes sur l'astra et
mikari venue non monsieur collard ne
soyez pas défaitiste et sidya ni la
guerre y avec nous y arrêter de sada
politique
loïc le mot de la fin pour vous bien sûr
que cette question éminemment politique
que cette année celle politique du
premier ministre à répondre aux besoins
sanitaires à protéger la population
française mais quand nous avons proposé
depuis des mois des pro des solutions
alternatives quand nous avons demandé
des licences d'office quand nous avons
demandé la transparence sur les contrats
des vaccins pouces a été balayée d'un
revers de la main
le gouvernement pense en être plus
intelligent tout seul quand des coûts
tant d'autres amis on en est aujourd'hui
dans une situation qui est
incroyablement compliqué difficile pour
tous les français et les françaises qui
sont face à cette pandémie qui n'a il
n'y a pas de réponse moi je dis à ceux à
ce niveau des chèques et à ce niveau
même d'un conséquence il faut en tirer
les conséquences
les conséquences sanitaires les
conséquences politiques monsieur castex
n'est pas en mesure de
la situation aujourd'hui il doit partir
et de laisser la place à quelqu'un qui
arrêtent de survie qui agit merci en
tout cas tous les 3 gb recoler cyrille
isaac 6000 et loïc peu d'hommes d'avoir
été avec nous après donc cette
conférence de presse de jean castex et l
instant faisant suite certainement aux
propos du premier ministre je vous le
rappelle 20 départements 20 régions qui
vont être sous surveillance et bien la
mairie de paris va proposer un
confinement de paris pour trois semaines
évidemment cette information va être
largement commenté on imagine puisque
plusieurs millions de personnes sont
concernées merci donc quelques instants
rester avec nous nous partirons en
israël le pays renforce son arsenal
législatif face au co vide le pays qui
vient d'adopter une loi permettant de
communiquer l'identité des personnes non
vaccinées provoquant la colère de
l'opposition
et puis direction l'arménie où le
président appelle à la retenue et au bon
sens le premier ministre a dénoncé ce
matin une tentative de coup d'état
[Musique]
depuis des décennies il s'est imposé
comme la devise incontournable dans le
commerce international le dollar peut-il
être détrôné détrôner pas encore c'est
pas quelque chose d'à ce faire en lice
jo à ce que veut faire les chinois c'est
qu'ils veulent des de l'arizona j parce
que le dollar à des folies qui viennent
et washington fournit le chinois ben si
ça vous fait rien on va régler nos
problèmes de liquidité entre asiatiques
et on va se débarrasser des états unis
aujourd'hui les instruments sont en
place pour pouvoir se passer les
transactions en dollars
faut pas avoir fait de longues études
pour savoir si la masse monétaire double
aux états-unis et dé change pas en chine
va probablement dans les années qui
viennent la monnaie chinoise a monté
vis-à-vis de la monnaie américaine et
donc grosso modo il semble que s'il
était un jeune homme je touche je
suivrai le conseil des parts à l'est
jeune homme pour une fois je paraphrase
ray monsieur macron c'est en marche
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes comment ces
mecs-là arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi
je pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inouï gilet jaune c'était des valeurs
de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la ligue
parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est on
dirait qu'il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
à 20h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct
sur rt france si vous nous rejoignez
israël renforce son arsenal législatif
assaut commis 19 le pays elle vient
d'adopter une loi permettant de
communiquer l'identité des personnes non
vaccinées
ces informations étaient auparavant
réservés au ministère de la santé
pourront désormais être délivrée à
d'autres organismes étatiques et noah
qui provoque la colère de l'opposition
israélienne t au combat c'est une courbe
qui fait la fierté du premier ministre
benyamin nétanyahou près de 50 % des
israéliens ont déjà reçu une première
dose de vaccin contre le coc u19
un chiffre impressionnant mais qui ne
suffit visiblement pas aux autorités la
knesset le parlement de l'état hébreu
vient de valider une loi permettant aux
ministères de la santé de transmettre
les noms adresses et coordonnées
téléphoniques des personnes non
vaccinées à d'autres institutions
objectif affiché encourager la
vaccination auprès des plus réfractaires
nous élus par le peuple pour essayer
d'améliorer leur qualité de vie
devons prendre des décisions les
vaccinations sont indispensables et
cette loi vise à augmenter le nombre
d'inoculation parmi ceux qui ont
l'impression de ne pas avoir besoin de
se faire vacciner
concrètement certains organismes publics
comme les municipalités pourront
contacter les personnes non vaccinées
pour les encourager à sauter le pas un
texte qui poursuit la politique
offensive du gouvernement face au co
vite 19 le pays avait déjà mis en place
un système réservant l'accès à certains
lieux publics aux détenteurs d'un badge
vert à savoir ce qu'ils ont reçu la
seconde dose du vaccin ou qui ont
récupéré de la maladie une loi
liberticide
aux yeux de l'opposition laquelle
dénonce une atteinte
vie privée ces informations
appartiennent aux citoyens et
aujourd'hui vous lorgnez leur droit à la
confidentialité sur leurs informations
médicales officiellement valable pour
une durée de trois mois ce texte
législatif pourrait être suivi par un
autre beaucoup plus sévère le ministère
de la santé pourrait prochainement
présenter une loi proposant d'interdire
aux employés notamment ceux de la santé
de l'éducation des transports publics ou
de la sécurité
l'accès à leur lieu de travail s'ils ne
sont pas immunisés guéri ou s'ils ne se
font pas tester régulièrement
une perspective qui a poussé hier
plusieurs dizaines d'israéliens à
manifester leur mécontentement à
tel-aviv est toujours en israël miami
netanyahu demande à joe biden de
maintenir la pression sur la cour pénale
internationale pour éviter une enquête
en palestine maintenir les sanctions
contre les membres de la cpi afin de
limiter la probabilité d'une enquête sur
des crimes de guerre commis à gaza et en
cisjordanie en 2014
de son côté l'administration américaine
a par ailleurs signalé son intention
d'examiner en profondeur ces sanctions
américaines et pour en parler nous
sommes avec jacques benillouche analyste
indépendant bonsoir jacques benillouche
merci d'être avec nous en direct de tel
aviv
que pourrait-on découvrir avec cette
enquête que craint si fort benyamin
nétanyahou est bien d'abord il faut dire
que nous avons un grand paradoxe en
israël puisque nous sommes parmi ceux
qui avons le plus grand pourcentage de
vacciner et pourtant le gouvernement
décide de confiner de conflit n'est
encore plus durement
pourquoi parce que nous avons encore pas
mal de bord entre 30 et 50 morts par
jour pour un petit pays comme israël
avec 9 millions de populations c'est
beaucoup et deuxièmement parce que on
souffre en israël des faits que news
on a trop de fair use de noms soient des
pays voisins des pays arabes voisins
soit lors des réseaux sociaux en israël
qui sont lus évidemment par tout le
monde
or
ces faits qui nous avons un problème
c'est qu'ils interdisent à certains de
se vacciner
on avait à une époque récemment jusqu'à
150 mille vaccinations par jour et nous
en sommes aujourd'hui à 120 mille cent
sept mille pardons
c'est à dire qu'en fait on a on a
beaucoup de doses de vaccins et on
n'arrive pas à vacciner les gens parce
que ils ont peur et pourtant les
résultats que nous avons des vaccinés ne
prête pas à confusion
les vaccins pour l'instant ne n'ont pas
de conséquences secondaires sur les
vacciner alors il est à je vais faire
une paraphrase si le vaccin ne vient pas
à nous c'est toi c'est nous qui irons au
vaccin et c'est pour ça qu'à l'heure
actuelle nous avons de temps en temps
dans certains quartiers des villes une
tante qui se monte pour bamboo pendant
une demi journée et pendant cette demi
journée ont fait appel à tous les
besoins tous les gens du voisinage qui
n'ont pas voulu se vacciner qui n'ont
pas pu se vacciner ou qu'ils n'ont pas
le temps de se vacciner
et ça c'est très important parce qu'on
s'est aperçu que la le le le nombre de
vaccinés augmente alors effectivement on
ne peut pas faire ça avant tout dans
tous les quartiers d'israël parce que
nous avons des réfractaires dans l'est
dans les villes les villes orthodoxe et
nous avons des réfractaires dans les
villes arabes ont des raisons qu'on peut
pas expliquer les arabes
l'or et les orthodoxes n'aime pas le la
validation
alors que nous avons à l'heure actuelle
à peu près 40 9 % des populations je
dirais normale entre guillemets qui sont
vaccinées eh bien on a que 23 %
dharam qui le sont et 35% d'orthodoxes
qui le sont donc voyez un écart alors
c'est cet écart dans la vaccination pose
un problème sécuritaire de sécurité
sanitaire c'est à dire que ces
populations
ne créez les contaminations très
importante
et puis un autre problème de plus en
plus grave c'est qu'il serait fermé les
aéroports aéroports le solaire au port
israélien de ben gourion et pour
interdire l'entrée des et des étrangers
deux à l'extérieur non seulement
l'entrée des étrangers
mais l'entrée des israéliens qui se
trouvent bloqués depuis 2,2 à peu près
deux mois
il ya deux mille israéliens qui sont
bloqués à l'étranger et qui ne peuvent
pas rentrer en israël
alors on a fait une loi permettant à 200
tous les jours 222 de rentrer mais il
serait la peur de l'extérieur
un exemple tout bête un avion a été
affrété pour des raisons sanitaires et
urgente venant d'eux de brooklyn aux
états unis eh bien les gens sont romands
sont montés dans les avions avec des
certificats soit disant authentique et
bien on s'est aperçu à l'arrivée lorsque
les tests ont été posées qu'il y avait
treize personnes dans l'avion qui avait
des faux papiers et qui étaient
contaminés et qu'ils étaient dangereux
alors c'est pour ça que à l'heure
actuelle on se pose des questions on se
pose des questions
face à l'émoi de vous couper parce qu'on
vous parliez de fake news etc
mais c'est vrai que les chiffres qu'on a
en france ils sont plutôt encourageants
surtout pour nous autres français qui
sommes voilà à moins de 3 millions de
de vaccination si je ne fais pas
d'erreur on nous annonce une baisse
spectaculaire des contaminations et des
décès dans l'état hébreu près de 49% de
la population qui a reçu au moins une
dose de paille versé ce n'est pas les
chiffres que vous avez vous vous
contestez tout à fait en a 4 millions
6,2 de d'israéliens qui ont reçu une
dose et nous avons exactement 3 millions
2 qui ont reçu deux doses donc sur une
population importante mais le problème
qu'il y assez qu'on apprend tous les
jours avec le coronavirus eh bien on
s'aperçoit à l'heure actuelle que les
jeunes sont touchés
et ça c'est quelque chose de nouveau
allons aller vacciner les gens au de ça
au delà de 65 ans ensuite au delà de 50
ans ensuite au delà de 40 ans et puis là
on s'aperçoit que de nombreux jeunes
sont contaminés par le corps n'a il y a
des jeunes qui sont dans les hôpitaux
qui souffre
il y a des il y à des femmes jeunes qui
sont enceintes et qui ont des problèmes
de corona c'est à dire que là le
gouvernement doit réviser sa politique à
savoir qu'il va falloir certainement
mobile est de vacciner en masse tous les
gens au-delà de 12 ans c'est ce qui est
prévu dans le programme israélien et
donc on a pris alors qu'on disait que
les jeunes n'étaient pas comme lui ne
communiquait pas le le le corona et bien
oui à l'heure actuelle on voyait qu'on
apprend tous les jours
et qu'à chaque fois qu'on qu'on avance
dans le temps on est forcé de changer
les conditions légales et c'est pour
cela que le gouvernement veut absolument
forcer les gens à ceux à ce ce maxi des
et il n'utilise des méthodes que dans
les pays dans d'autres pays on n'utilise
pas me sall et en israël
le monde et tous les gens sont fichés à
partir de leur numéro d'identification
on sait tout sur eux sur leur le sur
leur patrimoine sur leur compte en
banque sur leur situation sanitaire est
bien quand on voit maintenant
aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui n'est pas
vacciné et ça arrive
eh bien on prend le téléphone et on
l'appelle et on lui dit attention si tu
ne te vaccine pas pu risque d'avoir des
problèmes tu pourras pu rentrer dans les
restaurants
tu ne pourra plus voyager même on
interdira la sortie du pays donc vous
voyez quand les forces et effectivement
cela implique nous ayons un système
entièrement sophistiqué informatisé que
nous n'avons pas en france
parce que là la loi liberté sécurité ne
nous permet pas mais ici on a tous les
droits et de là c'est une c'est quelque
chose qui j'aime un petit peu
l'opposition mais devant le danger
je pense que il n'y a pas de mesure
mauvaise
on doit régler les problèmes par tous
les moyens qui sont à notre disposition
même des moyens qui importe atteint
dit-on à la liberté individuelle
un merci en tout cas jacques benillouche
d'avoir été avec nos journalistes
indépendants en direct de tel aviv 1
après un an d'isolement avec le reste du
monde l'algérie vient de durcir une
nouvelle fois l'accès à son territoire
notamment avec nos voisins tunisiens les
habitants transfrontalier déjà bien
impactées par la crise du coc vide
semble de plus en plus désemparés face à
l'absence d'algériens sur le territoire
reportage au nord ouest de la tunisie
avec bsn chebbi et verts m nasri des
montagnes des forêts à perte de vue
loin de l'agitation de la capitale au
nord ouest du pays à la frontière avec
l'algérie
tabarka in drame semble comme figé cette
région de villégiature prisé pour son
calme et son tourisme écologique sombre
jour après jour dans la détresse
économique hôteliers artisans et
commerçants ferment à tour de rôle face
à l'absence de touristes due à la crise
sanitaire du co lead et plus
particulièrement à l'absence des voisins
algériens qui représente près de 50% des
touristes de la région samhi
bendjaballah travaille le bois depuis
plus de dix ans ces créations
artisanales
il les vend sur la route point de
passage entre l'algérie et la tunisie
depuis près d'un an ses créations
prennent la poussière et les clients
sont devenus très rares comme beaucoup
d'artisans de la région il craint de
devoir fermer boutique
depuis la fermeture des frontières au
mois de mars de l'année dernière notre
activité a énormément baissé
on travaillait beaucoup avec nos voisins
algériens du coup aujourd'hui on
travaille quasiment plus en plus des
algériens on travaille également avec
les touristes étrangers notamment des
européens mais tout ça c'est fini il n'y
a plus de travail
il arrive parfois que je ne demande
aucune pièce pendant toute une semaine
il ne reste aujourd'hui plus que la
patience le nord-ouest compte une
dizaine de grands hôtels qui font vivre
une grande partie de la région depuis la
révolution de 2011 puis la crise du
colline près de quatre grands complexes
ont fermé leurs portes
kamel naïma et leila font partie de ces
dommages collatéraux c'est le coeur
serré et qui déambulent sur cette
promenade
autrefois bondés de touristes au chômage
technique
il regrette la fermeture des frontières
avec l'algérie nous sommes au chômage
technique depuis septembre et bien avant
septembre même on avait travaillé que
juillet et août depuis le début de la
crise au mois de mars
depuis la fermeture des frontières avec
l'algérie les conséquences se sont
alourdies car les algériens passent
toujours par notre région
pas seulement pour les vacances mais
aussi pour faire leurs achats et
profiter de nos marchés du coup les
magasins fonctionnent les hôtels
fonctionnent et même les petits
commerçants
les épiciers et les vendeurs de légumes
profil de cette clientèle algérienne
depuis cette fermeture les conséquences
sont lourdes pour tout le monde
une situation compliquée pour ces
professionnels du tourisme qui dénonce
l'inaction du gouvernement face à cette
crise économique qui paralyse la région
sur les quatre hôtels qui ont fermé on
ne comptait pas moins de 700 salariés
c'est un secteur qui nourrit beaucoup de
familles ici alors aujourd'hui que fait
le gouvernement où il est à il est
complètement absent nous souhaitons que
le chef de gouvernement prenne enfin ses
responsabilités et trouve rapidement une
solution à cette crise que nous vivons
ici
depuis la révolution et encore plus à
cause de la crise du coc vide
beaucoup sont au chômage sans aucune
indemnité
du côté des autorités représentées par
l'office du tourisme on tempère pour le
commissaire régional au tourisme
kovy des absences d'algériens ont certes
eu un impact sur l'économie locale
mais le bilan est loin d'être alarmant
selon les statistiques les touristes
algériens d'avant qu'ovide représenter
environ deux millions huit cent mille
personnes
parmi eux un million deux cent mille
transiter par la frontière avec tabarka
nous avons constaté en 2020 une
influence négative sur l'économie de la
région notamment depuis que notre voisin
algérien a fermé ses frontières
les touristes algériens avaient un grand
rôle sur l'économie de notre région
nous avons remarqué que beaucoup de
petits commerces et artisans avait un
contact direct avec ces voyageurs qui
avaient l'habitude de s'arrêter
fréquemment dans leur stand
il souffre aujourd'hui de cette
fermeture alors que les frontaliers des
deux bords espérer une réouverture
prochaine
le gouvernement algérien vient de
décider subitement de durcir les mesures
d'accès à son territoire depuis la
découverte d'un variant sur le sol
tunisien alors que seuls les
travailleurs et les marchandises munis
d'une autorisation de déplacement
pouvaient encore circulé entre les deux
pays
cette nouvelle mesure vient compliquer
la situation déjà très fragilisé un coup
dur supplémentaire pour des milliers de
transfrontalier déjà durement touchée
par la crise du corps d'un virus
une situation très tendue en arménie le
premier ministre accuse les forces
armées d'une tentative de coup d'état
après que des officiers supérieurs ont
signé une lettre appelant à sa démission
pourrait affirmer son autorité nikol
pashinian appelé ses partisans à se
rassembler hélène masquelier erevan en
ébullition ce jeudi le coeur de la
capitale arménienne est scindé en deux
place de la république les partisans de
nikol pashinian venus en nombre soutenir
le premier ministre d'un pas décidé
mégaphone à la main et à moins d'un
kilomètre de la place de la liberté
l'opposition qui appellent à la
démission du chef du gouvernement
à l'origine de cette crise politique la
lourde défaite militaire contre
l'azerbaïdjan 2 novembre dernier vécu
comme une humiliation nationale depuis
la fin du conflit au haut karabagh le
chef du gouvernement est sur la sellette
les manifestations se multiplient
organisées par l'opposition
désormais rejointe par l'armée hier
nikol pashinian a limogé le chef
d'état-major des armées ce qui a
exacerbé les tensions
entouré de ses partisans ce jeudi le
premier ministre a appelé l'armée à ne
pas intervenir dans le processus
politique du pays
certains veulent entraîner l'armée dans
des processus inconstitutionnelle il
s'agit d'une tentative de coup d'état
mais le peuple ne permettra pas un coup
d'état militaire en arménie du côté de
l'opposition les manifestants se rendent
vers l'assemblée nationale se préparant
à installer des chapiteaux il appelle à
occuper l'espace public jusqu'à la
démission de nikol pashinian le parti
arménie prospère de l'homme d'affaires
cadjee tsarukian a lancé un appel au
premier ministre
la déclaration de l'armée est en
tournant nous appelons nikol pashinian à
ne pas à mener le pays vers une guerre
civile et une
fusion de sang pashinian a encore une
chance de partir sans trouble côté
diplomatique la crise politique est
surveillée de près en particulier par la
russie et la turquie qui se disputent
l'influencent dans la région du caucase
du sud
le kremlin espérant de son côté un
règlement pacifique du conflit
nous suivons avec inquiétude l'évolution
de la situation en arménie
nous estimons que c'est une situation
exclusivement intérieure aux pays alliés
très proche et important pour nous dans
le caucase
nous appelons au calme le président
russe s'est entretenu au téléphone avec
nikol pashinian vladimir poutine qui a
appelé à un règlement de la situation
dans le cadre légal mais a aussi exhorté
chacune des parties à la retenue
et pour parler de cette situation nous
sommes avec jean de gliniasty directeur
de recherche à l'iris bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france ô nikol pashinian qui dénonce
donc un coup d'état militaire un putsch
est ce que c'est bien le cas ce qu'on
peut utiliser ces mots là pour l'instant
nous pour l'instant non ça commençait
par eux en fait c'est vais pas chignon
qui a commencé par limogé le chef
d'état-major adjoint
il ya eu une réaction de du chef d'état
major qui a signé une déclaration avec
eux énormément d'officiers d'officiers
supérieurs une grande partie de l'état
majeur demandant la démission de
pachinian et à la suite de sa pa chinian
a limogé le chef d'état-major
donc on est encore dans un dans un bras
de fer mais pas encore dans un coup
d'état
peut-être ne sera jamais si ça se règle
en douceur l'opposition n'a jamais
pardonné à nikol pashinian la défaite
arménienne lors du dernier conflit haut
karabagh baisse toujours que ton quand
on subit une défaite on cherche des
boucs émissaires on cherche le
responsable
la vérité est que pashinian est assez
peu responsables c'est la préparation
précédant 2
et des erreurs diplomatiques sur de
longues années qui ont conduit à ce à ce
désastre pour l'armée arménienne
il ne reste pas moins que la solution
actuelle le cessez-le-feu est l'état qui
en résulte n'est pas si défavorables en
fait à l'arménie parce que l'arménie n'a
pas perdu formellement le haut karabakh
les arméniens continuent à y vivre le
cou noir de latchine reste surveillé par
les plus c'est donc il peut communiquer
avec l'arménie peut communiquer avec le
haut karabakh
la seule chose qui a perdu en fait
l'armani c'est sept districts dont
l'arménie elle même considéré qu'il
n'était pas armé niamey que c'était
simplement une zone de sécurité
donc en fait l'accord du 10 novembre à
moscou est un accord qui est plutôt
favorable à l'arménie sur le plan
diplomatique
compte tenu de l'échec militaire qu'elle
avait subis donc en fait l'intérêt des
arméniens serait plutôt de de garder les
choses en l'état de ne pas provoquer de
deux changements nous pouvoir qui
risquerait d'abîmer au pouvoir des
reventes schiste et de relancer un
conflit qui pour l'instant en tout cas
compte tenu du rapport de force ne
jouerait pas en faveur de l'arménie
alors nikol pashinian tout cas peut
compter sur des soutiens on les a vu
défiler dans les rues d'airé vannes cet
après midi vingt mille soutien selon
l'afm enfin ya quand même eu de l'autre
côté en face à un défilé d'opposants ça
veut dire clairement qu on a une arménie
visés oui leurs manies et diviser c'est
toujours ennuyeux d'avoir d'avoir l'armé
contre soi parce que quand on regarde
les signataires de la déclaration
demandant le départ de deux pages ignore
il ya quasiment tout l'état major une
majorité des officiers supérieurs dont
il ya une divorce entre pashinian et
l'armée et ça évidemment dans un état de
semi guerre ou en tout cas la sortie de
la guerre cessez le feu qui quand même
reste précaire malgré les forces de
maintien de la paix plus c'est ennuyeux
au pas signés alors en tout cas
washington semble avoir pris position
d'une certaine manière en tout cas
puisque washington appelle ce soir à
l'instant d'ailleurs les forces armées à
ne pas intervenir dans les affaires
politiques au sujet donc de l'arménie
que vous inspire cette sortie
certainement du département peut-être
anthony blinken mais on ne sait pas
encore mais que vous inspire cette
déclaration américaine ce soir
bah écoutez ce que ce qui est notable
c'est que le président poutine téléphone
apache chinian le président r de wad
mais en tout cas les autorités turques
marque lors leur soutien indirect c'est
un peu le baiser qui tue mais enfin
quand même pas chinian le le département
d'état soutient pas signant je crois que
tout le monde considère que l'accord du
10 novembre et 1 est un équilibre
relativement satisfaisant et tout le
monde s'inquiètent d'une déstabilisation
nouvelles de la région comment justement
peut-on se sortir de cette division de
ce conflit interne à l'armée nie
désormais c'est dit c'est difficile à
dire parce que de toute façon il faudra
que il me semble pas un spécialiste des
affaires arménienne mais il me semble
que dans la psychologie collective
arménienne il faudra nécessairement un
bouc émissaire pour la défaite militaire
et la question de savoir qui sera le
bouc émissaire n'est pas encore réglé et
c'est là toute la difficulté
merci jean de gliniasty d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur arte
france dans quelques instants nous
reviendrons sur les conférences de
presse de jean castex et d'olivier véran
d'éventuelles restrictions
supplémentaires comme un confinement le
week-end sont envisagées pour 20
départements l'exécutif souhaite
attendre encore une semaine pour se
prononcer on vient d'apprendre ce soir
que la mairie de paris elle est proposé
au gouvernement un confinement de trois
semaines dans la capitale afin d'avoir
la perspective de tour ouvrira son issue
y compris les bars restaurants et lieux
culturels
[Musique]
comment vous jugez maintenant la façon
dont on a géré la crise parce que c'est
arrivé cette histoire personne ne
prenait pas au sérieux nos pieds il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont compris a pris
les choses en main mais c'est presque
inévitable que l'on met tout le monde
dans le même panier et à dire que la
boîte de nuit le bistrot de quartier
à quelles conditions pires gagna allons
nous pouvoir ré ouvrir les restos c'est
pas les clés mon jeu je produis je
travaille je
j'essaie de faire au mieux c'est aussi
tout un questionnement sur la société
sur le rapport à la solidarité et le
commerce
c'est le commerce et le sait le lien
entre dans le monde
est ce que vous vous allez vous faire
vacciner vous trois fois ci il faut un
évidemment
ajouté
certains disent que nous sommes pas une
chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même il
ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans on va te suicider
ça ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur ce retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que 1 et gaffe à ne l'appliquent pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom et no line quel rôle
pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu les big
for donc les gaffes à s'organiser pour
annuler quelqu'un sur internet ce que
quelqu'un s'était donald trump quand il
s'agit d'un bannissement si général pour
moi ce n'est pas aux gaffes à et aux
réseaux sociaux à dont l'un des
entreprises privées de prendre cette
décision mais ça doit être à la justice
de prendre cette décision
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
les accords d'abraham changer
l'équilibré stratégique pour le
moyen-orient après 50 ans d'immobilisme
dans cette région complexe run était le
seul à pouvoir créer les conditions
d'une paix durable grâce à ses relations
différentes avec tous les acteurs
le problème est maintenant de voir
comment joe biden va traiter le sujet si
ils relancent l'accord actuel les
accords d'abraham resteront une alliance
stratégique contre l'iran qu'une ira les
pays de la région et réglera les
relations avec israël
l'europe se cantonne dans le rôle de
spectateur sceptiques en ayant
totalement minimiser la dynamique créée
par les accords de bras si tout se
déroule comme l'envisageait donald trump
et ses négociateurs 2020 n'aura pas été
seulement l'année de lakovic 19
elle sera aussi celle des accords de
branche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous insistez beaucoup sur l'aspect des
dépenses publiques ce que je critique
c'est que on est dans un état
d'addiction de grande dépendance à la
dépense publique je ne veux pas du sang
et des larmes leçon il est l'âme on les
a déjà trop de dépenses trop d'état je
pense en tout cas qu'il ya trop de
bureaucratie c'est à dire un état
inefficace tout ça a été financée
essentiellement par de la dette
le problème est moins la dette en
réalité moi je pense qu'on remboursera
la dette par la croatie
donc il faut essayer de libérer
l'économie française et notamment le
travail
notre problème en france c'est un
problème où la dépense publique est
excessive
mais surtout elle n'est pas productive
les français n'en ont pas pour leur
argent
de ce point de vue là emmanuel macron
n'a rien changé par exemple par rapport
à son prédécesseur françois hollande
[Musique]
21h soyez les bienvenus en direct sur rt
francs si vous nous rejoignez pour cette
deuxième émission voici les titres de
l'actualité
vingt départements du nord de
l'ile-de-france de l'est et du sud est
placé sous surveillance renforcé
l'exécutif se donne une semaine pour
décider d'éventuelles mesures
supplémentaires dans ces territoires
comme un confinement le week end
paris a demandé au gouvernement une un
confinement total de trois semaines la
mairie l'a annoncé ce soir en attendant
la vaccination anti qu'ovide se poursuit
sa progression chez les plus fragiles
pourraient permettre une réduction des
restrictions sanitaires d'ici le mois de
juin conclu le premier ministre
les 27 dirigeants européens appellent à
maintenir des restrictions ferme face
aux variants du virus ils sont réunis en
sommet virtuel jusqu'à demain pour
tenter d'adopter une stratégie commune
et mène maintenant est actuellement en
train de s'exprimer le président
français insiste sur la nécessité que
l'europe soit plus autonome à l'avenir
dans la production de vaccins
[Musique]
le président arménien appel à la retenue
et au bon sens ils annoncent travailler
à des mesures urgentes pour désamorcer
la crise en arménie ce matin l'état
d'argent de l'état major de l'armée
appelé à la démission du premier
ministre nikol pashinian avec iron
retour a dénoncé une tentative de coup
d'état militaire des deux camps sont
descendus dans les rues de la capitale
et à l'instant washington appelle les
forces armées à ne pas intervenir dans
les affaires politiques en arménie et ce
soir dans l'édito échos zoom sur le
bitcoin à l'instar des crypto monnaies
qui pèse désormais quelques 1000
milliards de dollars mais le bitcoin
n'est pas le seul à flamber la bourse et
l'immobilier reste à des niveaux très
élevés malgré la crise
alors ce nouveau dans un monde de bulles
comment est-ce que tout cela peut se
finir autant de questions auxquelles
l'économiste jacques sapir tentera de
répondre
[Musique]
le coc vide on a donc appris tout à
l'heure la mairie de paris va proposer
au gouvernement un confinement de trois
semaines dans la capitale afin d'avoir
la perspective de tour ouvrira son issue
y compris bars restaurants et lieux
culturels annonce le premier adjoint
le premier ministre jean castex et
olivier verrey eux tenu une conférence
de presse tout à l'heure sur la
situation sanitaire
les départements sont surveillés comme
le lait sur le feu cette semaine les
précisions de nadège abderrazak nous
avons réussi à faire reculer la
propagation du commis 19 mais pas celle
des variants les propos sont signés elle
d'olivier 0 le ministre de la santé
était accompagné du premier ministre
jean castex 1 pour le point hebdomadaire
sur la crise sanitaire alors après et
nice et dunkerque 1 ou a été instauré un
confinement le week end on s'attendait à
ce que la mesure soit aussi appliqué sur
d'autres départements où la situation
est tout aussi critique mais ça n'a pas
été le cas
elle néanmoins un départements sont
désormais sous surveillance renforcée en
ile-de-france dans les hauts de france
en provence alpes côte d'azur dans la
drôme dans le rhône la moselle en
meurthe et moselle et en eure-et-loir
alors si la situation ne s'améliore pas
d'ici une semaine les mesures seront
renforcés à partir du week end du 6 mars
et on pourra en parler de confinement le
week end c'est en quelques sortes un
sursis que donne le premier ministre
j'ai demandé aux préfets des
départements concernés d'engager des
concertations avec les élus en vue
d'inviter sans attendre tous les
habitants à la plus grande vigilance et
d'envisager dans tout ou partie de ce
territoire des mesures de freinage
proches de celles mises en place à nice
et dunkerque
nous ferons un point au terme de ces
concertations la semaine prochaine et
nous déciderons alors si et seulement si
la situation continue à se dégrader
nous prendrons des mesures renforcées
qui entreront en vigueur à compter du
week-end du 6 mars une situation
sanitaire qui se dégradent donc d'après
le gouvernement qui a annoncé hier le
chiffre de 30 mille cas de contamination
au quotidien un record depuis le mois de
novembre
un chiffre qu'il faut malgré tout
relativiser pourquoi et bien parce que
lundi seuls 4000 cas de contamination
ont été enregistrées donc sur ses 30000
qu'a annoncé hier on peut surtout parlé
d'un retard une sorte de rattrapage en
comptabilité sur plusieurs jours
quoiqu'il en soit le virus est toujours
présent et la seule méthode efficace
pour lutter contre sa propagation
reste pour le gouvernement la
vaccination si vous êtes âgé de 75 ans
et plus et que vous vivez chez vous et
bien vous pouvez prendre rendez vous sur
internet sur le site sante.gouv.fr ou
par le numéro vert national ou en
appelant directement le centre le plus
proche de chez vous il y en a mille deux
cents sur toute la france mais prendre
rendez vous pour vous faire vacciner
avec ce qu'on appelle les vaccins à arn
messager nous espérons avoir terminé la
vaccination de toutes les personnes
âgées volontaires d'ici à la fin du mois
de mars permettant donc ensuite d'ouvrir
la vaccination aux 65 ans et plus si
vous êtes plus jeunes voire beaucoup
plus jeunes mais que vous figurer sur
une liste de personnes qui sont
atteintes de maladie particulièrement
grave et qui fait que vous êtes très
fragile aux risques du virus
vous pouvez aussi vous faire vacciner en
centre de vaccination avec une
prescription médicale avec les vaccins
de pfizer et moderna et puis sachez qu'à
partir d'aujourd'hui les médecins
généralistes vont pouvoir vacciner leurs
patients âgés de 50 à 64 ans présentant
des comorbidités donc susceptibles de
développer une forme grave de la maladie
voilà qui pourrait donc donner un coup
de boost à cette campagne de vaccination
qui prend son temps pour l'heure seuls
deux millions six cent mille français
ont reçu la première dose du vaccin et
compter d'aujourd'hui donc les
généralistes commence à vacciner leurs
patients les plus à risques on viens de
l'entendre une décision rassurante selon
les concernés côté il connaît ma maladie
c'est vraiment il a l'habitude de me
vacciner j'ai confiance plus confiance
en lui qui me connaît qu'il ne personne
je n'ai jamais
raconter ou là ça me soulage simon
préfère le vin ça m'a soulagé ce livre
est pour en parler nous sommes avec
l'eau de braun r médecins généralistes
strasbourg au vice-président du syndicat
l'union des généralistes bonsoir claude
bronner merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france de votre côté ce que vous
avez commencé à vacciner comment s'est
passée cette première journée
et bien aujourd'hui dans notre cabinet
les 20 premiers patients ou été
vaccinées par moi-même et un remplaçant
donc ça s'est très bien passé alors
racontez moi dites moi un peu plus
comment vous avez reçu les doses
combien de doses alors nous avait
proposé comme à tout le monde un flacon
par le médecin ne sommes un cabinet de 4
nous en avons commandé 4 et finalement
le pharmacien en a6 à disposition donc
nous n'avons aucun problème en ce moment
pour vacciner les personnes qui veulent
bien on a démarré aujourd'hui 22 mayan
aura sans doute encore 20 et début de la
semaine prochaine
on continuera encore après hambourg ont
signé mais il faudra que con et les
patients parce qu'il ya un moment où ça
va se ralentir les patients c'est à dire
parce qu'alors effectivement là vous
avez un discours tellement surprenant
attiré l'attention en plaisante un peu
toute la france où les français vont
venir vous voir à strasbourg pour se
faire vacciner parce que est quand même
plus une pénurie de vaccins que l'
inverse vous en tout cas vous n'avez pas
eu de problème justement à choisir entre
guillemets à trier les patients devoir
faire des choix vous parfois compliqué
comme certains autres médecins français
je crois que les choix ne sont pas si
compliqué ça parce qu'il y a aussi des
réticences de certains patients qui
attendent un peu que ça ait démarré donc
actuellement quand on propose à certains
patients de venir ils 18 mais ce n'est
pas non plus la ruée vers le vaccin mais
bien sûr que
ça va changer assez rapidement c'est
intéressant ce que vous le dit claude
bronner parce que le scepticisme des
français dont on a beaucoup parlé ici
même vous vous le ressentez quand même
encore clairement sur le terrain même si
les sondages ont tendance à aller dans
l'autre sens on le ressent un petit peu
mais en fait comme nous sommes les
médecins traitants déjà quand nous
proposons quelque chose c'est beaucoup
plus facilement acceptée et on a
vraiment l'impression que quand ce les
médecins habituels qui en parlent et qui
est lui même convaincu de l'intérêt du
vaccin
c'est quelque chose qui est bien écoutez
donc moi je n'ai pas vraiment ressenti
de de scepticisme
mais par contre j'ai entendu plusieurs
fois aujourd'hui bon bah si c'est vous
qui vous nous le proposer on est
d'accord
vous avez reçu quel type de vaccin est
est ce que l'accueil a été le même sur
toutes les marques de vaccins en ville
actuellement ne peut faire que l'astra
zeneca donc on a reçu un flacon
d'astrazeneca 10 doses
on peut même aller à 12 dans cette pour
certains flacons est et c'est le seul
que nous nous pouvons faire en ville et
les autres sont actuellement en centre
et c'est aussi celui qu'on ne peut faire
que jusqu'à 65 ans et ça laisse donc un
trou entre les 65 et 75 ans que la
plupart des patients regrette vraiment
beaucoup
alors j'ai souvent d'astrazeneca et a
beaucoup et pas de confusion mais enfin
de scepticisme autour de ce vaccin parce
qu'il a été rapporté que dans 10 % des
cas il y avait des effets secondaires
notamment chez certains soignants qu'ils
ont rapporté à ce que c'est compliqué
justement pour vous en cabinet de
n'avoir que ce vaccin à partir du moment
où il ya certains patients qui auront
des effets secondaires comment vous vous
organisez sur ce plan alors les effets
secondaires sont effectivement plus
nombreux que pour les vaccins
arn puisque ils sont en gros 10 fois
plus important mais mais on est à moins
de 1% des déclarations et et donc quand
on prévient les patients les effets
secondaires
c'est une journée de fièvre c'est des
courbatures et souvent les patients
disent ouais bah ça nous est déjà arrivé
dans le passé
c'est quelque chose qu'on va supporter
après je saurai demain ou après demain
s'il y en a qui vraiment vont me dire
ben dis-donc si j'avais su et
effectivement quand on a vacciné des
services de soignants qu on a vacciné un
peu tout le service
il est arrivé que le lendemain et un
tiers des personnes qui manquent pas ce
qu'ils ont dû prendre un jour de congé
donc il faut y penser il faut surtout
prévenir les patients
cela dit c'est pas cher payé pour être
probablement tranquille après oui c'est
ce que j'allais vous demandez docteur
c'est sans gravité parce qu'on nous dit
voilà circulez ya rien à voir on
entendait alain fischer tout à l'heure
lors de la conférence va nous expliquer
qu'il fallait prendre un doliprane
éventuellement en prévention mais en
face c'est ça s'arrête là les les effets
secondaires de zenica et c'est
finalement pas grave
oui on ne parle pas des faits graves on
parle des effets génome vaccin et qui
sont assez nombreux c'est au point que
l'asm la déclaration de la
pharmacovigilance a fait passer un
message pour dire arrêtez de nous
déclarer les fièvres et les courbatures
à mon avis c'était un peu noyé
mais c'est vrai que la consigne c'est de
ne pas les déclarer puisque c'est connu
et que ses attendus
alors le premier ministre a évoqué des
autres traitements les premiers
traitements à base d'anticorps
monoclonaux qui seront prochainement
disponibles en français une thérapie
prometteuse selon vous mais ça fait ses
preuves puisque on diminue en gros les
hospitalisations d'un facteur 4
donc c'est vraiment intéressant et là
aussi
a strasbourg les les tout premiers
patients ont été sélectionnés
aujourd'hui ils n'ont pas encore eu les
les injections
enfin la perfusion mais mais ça se met
en route et ça se met en route de
manière extrêmement rapide
merci en tout cas dr bronner médecin
généraliste à strasbourg vice président
du syndicat de l'union des généralistes
d'avoir été avec nous pour évoquer donc
cette première journée de vaccination
dans les cabinets des généralistes merci
à vous et direction cavens comme toutes
les villes du littoral entre menton et
théoule sur mer la croisette va se
reconfigurer le temps de deux week-ends
pour tenter de freiner la flambée
épidémique qui fait rage dans la région
le taux d'incidence y est trois fois
supérieur à la moyenne nationale alors
que le variant angles et représentent
50% des cas walid et nani des
températures estivales
un déjeuner face à la mer mais la vie
d'avant le kovy 19 loin d'avoir repris
son cours
le mot confinement plus que jamais
d'actualité sur la croisette
bah oui parce que bon vous avez vu le
temps qu'on a il fait très très beau les
gens si vous regardez les trois quarts
ils ont le masque elle a donc voila moi
je pense que les gens ne respectent pas
vraiment le masque tout le temps à
l'extérieur quoi en espérant qu en
confinant ça passe du bien que sa puce
être confiné que les gens respectent et
puis par la suite on puisse être un
petit peu plus libre en maintenant
l'histoire de confiner le week-end faut
essayer
faut voir on va essayer pendant deux
week-ends voire 4 parce qu'à mon avis
deux week-ends c'est trop juste
on peut pas dire si c'est valable ou pas
on verra l'avenir nous le dira les deux
prochains week end sous le signe donc de
la responsabilité citoyenne du vendredi
18 heures à lundi 6 heures les sorties
d'une heure autorisé mais seulement pour
motif impérieux travail
rendez vous médical promenade jusqu'à 5
kilomètres autour du domicile après le
confinement pour le week-end un bon jeu
restait quand même dubitatif parce que
moi je sais pas si ça va servir vraiment
à quelque chose que les gens la semaine
vont se concentrer plus la semaine est
pour moi sortir le week-end moi je
descends je fais ma marche avant de
venir au moule je passe par le succès
c'est tout faire mais ça fait drôle quoi
donc c'est vrai que ça touche énormément
d'un point de vue économique c'est dur
c'est dur pour les chants des cannois
sceptiques et compatissons envers les
restaurateurs et travailleurs du
dimanche
aujourd'hui les commerces de plus de
5000 m² sont fermés les magasins de
première nécessité les pharmacies ou
encore les enseignes de bricolage et
jardinage sont exemptés d'une fermeture
aux conséquences dévastatrices
à l'image de ce restaurant le plus vieil
établissement de cannes créée en 1860 le
kabuto prisée par les célébrités dispose
de 200 couverts aujourd'hui la joie et
l'effervescence a laissé place à la
colère
nos personnels sont reclus chez eux sont
en dépression
on est en train de tuer les forces vives
de ce pays un ancien de d'appauvrir et 2
et 2 et de paupériser complètement nos
commerces nos nos restaurants et nos
brasseries laissé à nous chefs
d'entreprise le soin de prendre soin de
nos clients ces mesures qui sont prises
sur notre région et sur les alpes
maritimes
elles sont la conséquence unique de
cette vague migratoire qui arrivent
d'italie et qui dépasse stopper à noter
également que les commerces de plus de
400 mètres carrés sont autorisées à
rester ouvert sans grande affluence
une nouveauté un médiateur qu'ovide
parmi les salariés
et devra veiller au respect strict des
gestes barrières
la campagne de vaccination ne sera pas
suffisant pour éviter un nouveau pic
d'hospitalisation en france est le
constat fait par l'institut pasteur dans
une étude publiée cette semaine
en cause la progression des variantes
sur le territoire les prévisions les
plus pessimistes sont alarmantes d'avis
khalifa non se faire vacciner ne devrait
pas réglé tous les maux de cette crise
sanitaire sans fin la mutation
britannique du commis 19 est le
principal responsable des projections
alarmantes réalisée par l'institut
pasteur selon cette étude le variant
angles est estimée de 50% à 60% plus
contagieux que la souche historique
devrait représenter la majorité des
nouveaux cas
dès le 1er mars et la quasi-totalité à
mois plus tard ces prévisions sont
calculées en fonction des restrictions
imposées à ce jour par le gouvernement
vous l'aurez donc compris sans mesures
supplémentaires les hôpitaux risquent
une saturation dans un scénario à 50%
on parvient en mai un pic
d'hospitalisation comparable à celui de
novembre 2020
dans un scénario à 60% on serait bien au
delà du pic d'avril 2020 étant donné les
incertitudes sur l'évolution des taux de
transmission du virus historique
il reste difficile de dire quand la
situation à l'hôpital se dégradera
fortement les graphiques de l'étude en
question sont édifiants vous le voyez la
situation restera compliquée sans
réduction supplémentaire des taux de
transmission c'est à dire sans
restriction supplémentaire et donc pour
parler clairement probablement un
nouveau confinement en mai juin le
nombre de nouvelles hospitalisations
pourrait frôler 4500 par jour contre
environ 3750 au pic de la première vague
est un peu plus de 2500 pour la deuxième
quid donc de l'efficacité de la
vaccination
à ce stade la vaccination ne va pas
fondamentalement réduire le nombre de
personnes infectées mais comme elle
cible en priorité les personnes les plus
fragiles
elle va assez vite avoir un impact sur
les hospitalisations
si au 1er avril on a vacciné 70 % des
plus de 75 ans le nombre
d'hospitalisations sera 28 % plus faible
que sans vaccins au 1er mai
il sera plus bas de 40 6% c'est un point
positif
un mince espoir est permis pour
contrecarrer ce scénario peu
encourageants ce serait de respecter le
calendrier vaccinal établi par
l'exécutif voit le dépasser si à partir
du 1er avril quatre cent mille doses par
jour étaient injectés
cela permettrait de ramener le pic à
peine au dessus de celui de novembre
sans prendre de mesures restrictives
supplémentaires
mais au vu de la tournure que prend la
campagne de vaccination en france ce
n'est pas l'hypothèse retenue du côté du
gouvernement on commence justement à
prévoir le pire
la piste de restrictions locales comme
celle déjà mise en place sur le littoral
des alpes-maritimes ou à dunkerque
semble être la plus plausible
tous nos efforts doivent se poursuivre
pour éviter d'avoir à décider d'un
nouveau confinement nationale sans
évidemment certitude que nous y
parviendrons mais depuis maintenant
plusieurs semaines plusieurs mois c'est
ce que vous m'entendez vous dire mais
nous avons une stratégie cette stratégie
je le disais c'est la capacité à
respecter les gestes barrières les
règles du couvre-feu
une méthode contestée ou jugée
insuffisante de plus en plus de
spécialistes affirment que le
confinement appliquée seulement le
week-end ne suffira pas le virus il se
propage aussi dans la semaine je pense
qu'il faut vraiment diminué les
interactions sept jours sur sept et
qu'il faut donc éviter que les gens se
rencontrent en dehors du cercle familial
on te voit une cette carte comme et
trakr publié par santé publique france
les zones les plus foncées représentent
les situations où les taux de
contamination sont les plus alarmants
mais bon souvenez vous au moment
d'annoncer un nouveau confinement le 28
octobre dernier
emmanuel macron prédisait quoi que nous
fassions 9000 patients en réanimation mi
novembre au 15 novembre
on trouvait en réanimation moitié moins
de patients que les prévisions du
président de la république des
prévisions basées là aussi sur les
modélisations de l'institut pasteur
quoi qu'il arrive la vaccination de
masse semble être eu tout de même une
solution viable
le gouvernement joue ses dernières
cartes de popularité alors retarder
l'échéance d'un nouveau confinement
général d'une main pour mieux masquer de
l'autre l'échec d'une campagne de
vaccination qui peine à démarrer
l'hypothèse est osé la vérité est celle
des chiffres n'ont pas projeter ou
fantasmé mais bien ceux de la vire est
le cas suédois ou les autorités refusent
et vous vous en souvenez jusqu'à présent
de confiner la population mais le rebond
épidémies dues aux variants anglais
oblige le gouvernement scandinave à
revoir sa copie julien du rô le pays
faisait partie de ceux dont la pandémie
n'avait pas trop perturber le quotidien
mais aujourd'hui la suède est inquiète
touché par un variant angles est plus
dévastateur le pays a enregistré 5371
nouvelles contaminations ce mercredi un
chiffre qui peut sembler dérisoire vu de
france mais qui représente une hausse
considérable pour la suède et ses 10
millions d'habitants
le variant britannique se propage très
rapidement il sera très probablement la
souche dominante d'ici quelques semaines
afin d'éviter de nouveaux décès le
gouvernement suédois a annoncé de
nouvelles mesures ce mercredi en plus de
l'interdiction de la vente d'alcool
après 20 heures à compter du 1er mars
les restaurants bars et cafés fermeront
leurs portes à 20h30
le nombre de personnes réunies dans l'e
commerce sera lui limité dans les
régions les plus peuplées du pays le
port du masque sera quant à lui
recommandé dans les commerces transports
et lieu de travail
des mesures qui ont pour objectif
d'éviter une troisième vague épidémique
tout en gardant une vie presque normale
moins de treize mille décès imputés au
co vite 19 ont été enregistrés sur le
territoire suédois depuis le début de
l'épidémie
alors comment mettre fin à la pandémie
et revenir à une vie normale c'est
l'objet d'un nouveau sommet européen à
distance sur le kobe 19
les membres de l'union européenne tente
d'afficher leur unité son dépit de
restriction de circulation non
coordonnées et de vives divergences sur
le futur passeport vaccinale le
président macron a tenu à clarifier la
position de la france concernant la
situation épidémiologique et la
stratégie vaccinale écouter
s'agissant de la situation actuelle nous
nous sommes accordés sur l'urgence de la
lutte contre les variantes du virus et
avons soutenu le lancement par la
commission d'une sorte de barda
européenne era qui va réunir laboratoire
chercheurs industriels régulateurs et
s'appuyer sur des financements européens
afin que nous puissions être au rendez
vous de l'innovation de la production et
de la livraison de produits de santé en
europe
notre objectif est de sécuriser les
commandes passées de continuer à
produire davantage en europe et nous
avons encore vu cette semaine l'annoncé
de plusieurs laboratoires qui ont
accepté de convertir des sites de
production pour produire des vaccins
existants et homologué et de préparer la
production future
l'union européenne se met en capacité de
produire comme l'a dit la commission
européenne de manière beaucoup plus
autonomes à partir de la fin d'année et
de manière durable car il est
vraisemblable que nous aurons à vivre
avec ce virus dans la durée et donc à
poursuivre des campagnes vaccinales
il faudra renforcer précisément cette
autonomie européenne reste avec nous
dans quelques instants un ou par l'avant
de l'arménie ou président appelle à la
retenue et au bon sens le premier
ministre nikol pashinian a dénoncé ce
matin une tentative de coup d'état et
puis nous évoquerons le bitcoin la star
des crypto monnaies qui pèse désormais
quelques 1000 milliards de dollars avec
l'économiste jacques sapir
[Musique]
depuis des décennies il s'est imposé
comme la devise incontournable dans le
commerce international le dollar peut-il
être détrôné détrôner pas encore c'est
pas quelque chose d'à ce faire en un
jour ce que le fait des chinois qui
veulent des de l'arizona j parce que le
dollar à des folies qui viennent de
washington aujourd'hui les chinoises si
ça vous fait rien on va régler nos
problèmes de liquidité entre asiatiques
et on va se débarrasser des états unis
aujourd'hui les instruments sont en
place pour pouvoir se passer des
transactions en dollars
faut pas avoir fait de longues études
pour savoir si la masse monétaire double
aux états unis et des changements en
chine va probablement dans les années
qui viennent la monnaie chinoise a monté
vis-à-vis de la monnaie américaine et
donc grosso modo il semble que s'il
était un jeune homme je suivre le
conseil de barral est jon hamm
pour une fois je paraphrase ray monsieur
macron c'est en marche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience du concert symphonique qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous oui mais
l'art en général vous savez ça permet de
mieux se connaître ça permet de mieux
partager c'est la part d'humanité
incontournable et indispensable à
l'évolution de tout être humain quand
vous entendez pata pata pata pata pata
pata pata pata pata pata papa parents
pata pata
vous avez envie de faire ça mais il faut
que leur qu'istres groove la musique
c'est la traduction la plus poétique de
la vie si vous mettez pas la vie des
évidemment on s'embête il faut sortir
les notes de leurs univers carcéral
mais il faut jouer ce qu'il ya entre les
notes et avant tout c'est le rythme et
la pulsation et ça c'est fondamental
pour entraîner l enthousiasme des
musiciens et celui du public
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde je suis
répond appartement on est énervé dans le
sentiment qu'il faut à chaque fois se
battre ils vivent parfois au bord des
routes nationales pas forcément loin de
paris mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent
moi je vois des remarques ont ils
fassent un tour de tracts avec boucle
une grande campagne il faut savoir c'est
qu'une vie différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles bas pourrait t'aider un peu
plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
les accords d'abraham change les
équilibres stratégiques pour le moyen
orient
après 50 ans d'immobilisme dans cette
région complexe run était le seul à
pouvoir créer conditions d'une paix
durable grâce à ses relations
différentes avec tous les acteurs
le problème est maintenant de voir
comment joe biden va traiter un sujet
s'il relance l'accord actuel des accords
d'abraham resteront une alliance
stratégique contre l'iran qui unira les
pays de la région et réglera les
relations avec israël
l'europe se cantonne dans le rôle de
spectateur sceptiques en ayant
totalement minimiser la dynamique créée
par les accros de bras si tout se
déroule comme l'envisageait donald trump
et ses négociateurs 2020 n'aura pas été
seulement l'année de lakovic 19
elle sera aussi celle des accords de
branche
[Musique]
un certain lien de confiance est rompu
entre le politique et les experts et
même les citoyens on est une société qui
est totalement percuté et on ne peut pas
considérer une démocratie vit
véritablement une amplitude de ses
possibles et l'amplitude de ses valeurs
quand elle est à ce point confiné est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment qu'on repart
à zéro par rapport à l'année dernière
la société ne survivra pas à une
succession de confinement une société
c'est pas de confinement
c'est la liberté c'est la créativité
c'est le sentiment d'exister
d'appartenir comment on va réorganiser
le monde est vrai que la pandémie c'est
vivre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
1 21h temps de souhaiter bienvenue en
direct sur rt france si vous nous
rejoignez situation particulièrement
tendue en arménie le premier ministre
dénonce un coup d'état est un major de
l'armée réclament la démission du
gouvernement la veille
nikol pashinian a limogé le chef du
commandement militaire
depuis plusieurs semaines le premier
ministre arménien est sous le feu des
critiques l'opposition réclament son
départ
le président quant à lui annonce
travaillaient des mesures urgentes pour
désamorcer la crise écoutez je lance
immédiatement des mesures visant à faire
réduire les tensions et trouver des
moyens de parvenir à une résolution
pacifique de la situation
j'appelle tous à faire preuve de
sobriété et de retenue j'appelle tout le
monde les organes d'état les organes de
sécurité les forces politiques les
citoyens à faire preuve de raison tout
mot au discours imprudent fait monter
les tensions notre peuple ne peut se
permettre une division il faut rejeter
toute tentative de déstabilisation et
agir dans le strict respect de la
constitution élections à l'étranger une
tentative de putsch fermement condamnées
par la turquie et face à cette tension
croissante la russie se dit préoccupé
par la situation
le kremlin appel au calme les précisions
depuis moscou avec antoine claireaux les
événements s'accélèrent en arménie le
premier ministre a pris la parole sur la
place de la république appelant l'armée
à protéger les frontières et l'intégrité
territoriale de l'arménie et non à
intervenir dans le processus politique
du pays
l'opposition a quant à elle annoncé
vouloir occuper la place de la liberté
l'autre grande place du centre d revan
toutes les nuits jusqu'à la démission de
nikol pashinian au cours de la journée
l'aviation militaire à voler au dessus
de la capitale arménienne plusieurs
arrestations de manifestants ont eu lieu
la tension a clairement montée d'un cran
au niveau diplomatique le ministre
arménien des affaires étrangères s'est
entretenu avec son homologue russe
sergueï lavrov qui a dit espérer un
règlement pacifique de ce conflit
le porte-parole du kremlin a aussi fait
part de ses inquiétudes
nous suivons avec inquiétude l'évolution
de la situation en arménie
nous estimons que c'est une affaire
exclusivement intérieure à l'arménie
allié très proche et important pour nous
dans le caucase
nous appelons au calme bien évidemment
nous estimant que la situation doit
rester dans le cadre constitutionnel
en plus des relations bilatérales très
étroit traditionnel riche en traditions
l'arménie est également très importante
pour nous en termes de coopération au
sein de l'union économique eurasiatique
l'eau ts et la coi et cetera
c'est une dimension majeure de notre
coopération
bien sûr il ya aussi l'objectif très
important de poursuivre la mise en
oeuvre de l'ensemble des dispositions du
document tripartite sur le règlement
dans le haut-karabagh signé il ya
quelques mois
à l'heure actuelle il n'y a pas eu de
contact mais vous savez que si
nécessaire moscou et erevan entreront en
contact assez rapidement la turquie qui
a joué un rôle important dans le récent
conflit dans le haut karabakh a
également réagi par la voix de son
ministre des affaires étrangères nous
nous opposons aux coups d'état ou aux
tentatives de coups d'état partout dans
le monde
par conséquent nous condamnons fermement
la tentative de putsch en arménie les
tentatives de putsch ne peuvent que
déstabiliser la région et c'est
d'ailleurs pour cette raison que nous
nous y opposons dans les démocraties les
citoyens peuvent critiquer le
gouvernement voire exiger sa démission
c'est naturel et que l'armée appelle à
démissionner un gouvernement qui est
arrivé au pouvoir par des élections sans
même parler d'un coup d'état
cela est inacceptable depuis la fin des
hostilités dans le haut karabakh au mois
de novembre dernier et les pertes de
territoires qu'ils ont accompagné le
premier ministre arménien s'est retrouvé
sur la sellette
une partie de la population l'opposition
politique est donc dorénavant l'état
major de l'armée de
mende sa démission mais on vient de
l'évoquer nikol pashinian n'est pas
disposé à se laisser faire et le premier
ministre arménien qui dénonce donc un
ponte une tentative de coup d'état
militaire nikol pashinian et depuis des
semaines sous la pression de
l'opposition qui réclame sa démission en
cause bien sûr en sous main la défaite
militaire de l'arménie face à
l'azerbaïdjan en décembre dernier dans
le haut-karabagh alors la chimio
dernières victimes de ce conflit c'est
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir et
pour en parler tigran et gabian
chercheurs vous êtes l'auteur également
de minorités d'orient les oubliés de
l'histoire aux éditions du rocher à vos
côtés saoudite ben ali juriste et
spécialiste du droit des étrangers
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être en
direct sur l'antenne d'arte et france
donc le premier ministre arménien très
contestée c'est moins qu'on puisse dire
en depuis des semaines 1 2 puis
d'ailleurs l'accord de cessez-le-feu qui
a donné d'importants territoire à
l'azerbaïdjan ses opposants le décrivent
comme un traître
quelle est votre position à vos outils
granby est gagnant écoutez je pense que
on est on est plus dans cette rhétorique
des retraites reversus ce patriote
l'arménie d'un pays moderne démocratique
qui doit construire son état est pas
construire un régime
or le souci de cette situation ce qui
est en train de se passer aujourd'hui
c'est que on est deux ans après une
révolution de velours cave était
justement un vrai bouleversement dans le
toute la région du caucase puisque pour
la première fois l'arménie sortie du
post soviétique mais on avait un vrai
pouvoir
on va dire légitime porteur d'une
promesse de modernisation et on se voit
que nikol pashinian s'était appuyé sur
la société civile pour pouvoir renverser
un régime honni que toute critique est
là en définitive ce régime final ce
n'est pas vraiment un état qui l'a
construit mais un régime
donc l'état arménien est
considérablement fragilisé par par cette
défaite donc passe à l'azerbaïdjan et le
souci c'est ce que nikol pashinian va
comprendre que l'intérêt super de l'état
passe avant sa personne et ses intérêts
puisque après on peut constater qu'il
n'est pas vrai sable
le mans dans l'autocritique et a
beaucoup de mal à accepter leur réelle
la réalité le problème c'est qu'en face
il n'y a pas si vous voulez de figure
dans l'opposition capable de fédérer
il suffit de constater aussi le peu
d'intérêt que la population arménienne à
mai à vis de l'opposition qui est assez
résiduelles vous voyez aujourd'hui avec
des grands rassemblements à erevan qui
n'ont pas galvanisé les foules après
vingt mille personnes ont manifesté aux
côtés de nikol pashinian contre à peu
près 13 ou 15 milles pour l'opposition
donc on a une population en minimes qui
est fatigué qui a sommé inquiets
assommés par cette part cette défaite du
novembre mais qui n'aspirent qu'à vivre
en paix et à se reconstruire se
reconstruire sur les ruines
or pour se reconstruire il est difficile
d'envisager nikol pashinian comme un
homme capable de pouvoir mener la barque
puisque il y a une impression de vide de
pouvoir en arménie qui est sujette à
toutes les craintes notamment les
craintes de sécurité puisque nous avons
comme une poursuite des hostilités avec
l'azerbaïdjan notamment dans le la
frontière de la région du sud de l'eure
mais il a encore quand même des
partisans nikol pashinian vingt mille
partisans ont exercé par delà toute
l'arménie mais enfin quand même y en
avait que 13 milles de l'autre côté si
on devait faire une comptabilité
je vous pose la même question aux amours
sadique ben ali
il doit partir au nikol pashinian il a
signé un si mauvais accord avec
l'azerbaïdjan en décembre dernier parce
qu'on entendait par exemple un expert
tout à l'heure un directeur de recherche
à l'iris tout dire bah c'est pas si
mauvais finalement pour l'arménie alors
c'est vrai qu'il ya un petit peu tous
les sons cloche alors d'abord merci
beaucoup pour pouvoir encore des
batteries sur rt france je vois croire
que ces seuls en france malheureusement
et moi je je suis prêt comme je dis
débattre à tout avec toute personne
arménienne sur la situation puisque ça
nous préoccupe tous en cinq ans et le
troisième conflit entre nos deux pays je
pense que c'est inacceptable au vu du
nombre des pertes ou même qu'il a eu des
puits alors ce qui se passe avec
aujourd'hui avec pashinian
malheureusement il est pris
dans l'étau de sa propre de sa propre
politique c'est à dire que même si c'est
un pouvoir démocratique arrivé avec les
pouvoirs des révolutions des vélos il
s'est enfermé tout pouvoir mignon tout
et ça me chagrine depuis 30 ans s'est
enfermé dans cette logique de la haine
et de xénophobie de leurs revendications
territoriales le voisin donc même tout à
l'heure vous savez quand vous parlez du
territoire perdu ma fait il s'agite pas
les territoires perdus sel et héritant
d'un airbag et ils ont reconnu par le
droit international
donc on ne peut pas parler de ça
pashinian malheureusement il a continué
le jeu sur cette note nationaliste du
peuple arménien n malheureusement il a
eu conflit est il à la cour qui est
signée le 9 novembre
je pense que cet accord doit être
exécutée et l'arménie doivent faire ce
travail profond de travail sur elle-même
sur son histoire sur son passé pour
aller vers l'avenir je pense qu'il n'y a
aucune à venir aucune possibilité que
les faucons aujourd'hui arrive au
pouvoir parce qu'il sait c'est de ça
qu'il s'agit
pashinian peut-être il convient pas tout
le monde mais aux yeux de l'alternative
qu'il a devant nous ça veut dire les
faucons qui vont arriver au pouvoir qui
vont encore je sais de carte
nationaliste et encore quoi encore
s'armer l'arménie encore la guerre
encore nouveaux morts est encore nouveau
père tu perds tu divises humain je pense
que c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre je
pense
dans cette perspective que le communauté
internationale et là je leur la jouer
tous les pays d'ailleurs l'union
européenne aussi parce qu'il faudra
aider donc larminier à devenir plus
démocratique il faut croire que la ruine
se débarrasse de cette c'est un passé
qui le poursuit de se passer de 7 avec
ses neuf obus envers le voisin ses
revendications territoriales
territoriale de cette mia zum qui plane
comme une épée damoclès où les arméniens
jeu c'est rare originaire de l'armee
vous savez je suis né là bas je suis
vécu là-bas 11 ans et un jour tout toute
ma vie s'est effondré mais compatriotes
comme à 258 son parti de 117 109 et
après aujourd'hui regardez on est on est
à laver donc 25 février demain c'est
l'anniversaire triste de massacres
djallit qu'est ce que ça coûte cher et
c'est arrivé de cette haine envers
nazeri à tel point que 26 février
les militaires arméniens haut karabakh
ils ont commis les crimes atroces
abominable
les 213 civils hommes femmes dans le
centre étaient massacrés sans aucun
disque ixion et les autres au titre
étaient torturés aussi subi les sévices
et 150 d'ailleurs n'était jamais été
retrouvé donc je pense que la
conséquence c'est la conséquence de ce
qui se passait c'est la haine qui a été
cultivé regardez moi je t'ai jeu suivant
de part d'audience
c'est toujours compliqué pardonnez moi
je suis obligée de l'east river la
parole vous êtes à deux et on n'a pas
toute la nuit mais franchement cigales
des gabians oui mais je pensais pas que
rt france et est le réceptacle d'un
propagandistes du régime hasard alors je
vous en ai tigran gharamian n'est pas le
respect de réceptacle de personnes n'ont
pas toutes les opinions sont bonnes à
entendre et vous êtes justement là pour
apporter la contradiction donc je vous
en prie allez-y madame excusez-moi
entendez moi bien je suis pas ici pour
participer en tant qu'acteur à un combat
de coqs
ça ne m'intéresse absolument pas de
pratiquer ce que monsieur donc monsieur
de azerbaïdjanais a pratiquement pas de
la version accusatoire c'est à dire
c'est l'agresseur qui est l'agressé ça
c'est hors sujet ça n'intéresse personne
intéressons nous plutôt au sujet
d'aujourd'hui c'est qu'est ce qui a
conduit nikol pashinian là où il est et
quelles sont les zones gros les zones
d'ombré aussi de la défaite arménienne
du karabagh moi je me pose plusieurs
questions notamment les conditions de la
chute de shoushi la capitale historique
du karabagh pourquoi l'aéroport de
stepanakert n'a pas été bombardé par les
airs et pourquoi la présidence de
stéphane de la soeur de la tsarine
stepanakert n'a pas été bombardé par les
azéris ainsi des questions intéressantes
que beaucoup d'arméniens s'oppose non
moi ce que je voulais qu'on prend
surtout c'est que en arménie nikol
pashinian continue à avoir un certain
soutien populaire pour deux raisons
essentielles
la première c'est que beaucoup de mères
de famille de parents de soldats ne
souhaite pas envoyer leurs enfants
karabagh se battre ils et les conditions
on l'a bien vu sont assez affligeante on
a menti bourg sur l'état des arts de
l'armée et la deuxième question sigle
pour l'ancien de la population la
majorité car la population ne souhaite
pas un retour à l'ancien régime qui
était avant tout un régime
kleptocratique un régime qui a vécu
pendant 30 ans dans une situation de
rente stratégique
un régime qui a confondu victoire
militaire sur l'azerbaïdjan avec
victoire politique
hélas oui effectivement il ya une grande
une grande confusion un grand souci si
vous voulez d'appréhension du réel je
crois que le principal problème des
arméniens c'est la privation du réel et
c'est aussi le fait qu' ils considèrent
les a virés comme des turcs puisqu'ils
sont turcophones et vous avez la plaie
du génocide de 1915 qui plane sur les
horizons vous avez un état négationniste
s'appelle la turquie qui participent
activement à qui a participé activement
à l'extermination des arméniens au début
du 20e siècle et continue son processus
d'extermination
après le génocide en s'alliant avec les
aziri donc il ya un vrai traumatisme il
faut sortir de ce traumatisme
et pour cela il faut comprendre que on
peut pas continuer dans cette même
configuration danse avec un comment dire
un pouvoir azerbaïdjanais qui pratiquent
le pentu requises pour arriver à ses
fins donc vous voyez il ya un déni mais
alors on a été coupée tigran l'avion
merci à vous à oudezeele libanais on
arrive déjà à l'issue de ce débat en
tout cas merci d'avoir exprimé vos
opinions direct ce soir sur arte france
merci à vous deux un record à 58 milles
dollars puis une chute de 20% les jours
suivants il faut avoir le coeur bien
accroché pour suivre le bitcoin la star
décrite aux monnaies qui pèse désormais
quelques 1000 milliards de dollars mais
le bitcoin n'est pas le seul à flamber
la bourse et l'immobilier reste à des
niveaux très élevés malgré la crise
alors sommes-nous dans un monde de
bulles
comment est-ce que tout cela peut finir
on en parle tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir c
nistos échos ce soir bonsoir
jacques bienvenu bonsoir c'est fanny
alors jacques que se passe-t-il sur
certains marchés d'actifs comme les
crypto monnaies est ce que des petites
bulles sont en train de se former
oui c'est tout à fait évident alors on a
déjà le problème de la bourse qui est à
un niveau tout à fait historiquement
hauts
et puis vous avez parlé évidemment du
marché du bit coin le bitcoin il est
aujourd'hui à un niveau qui est dix fois
supérieur à son niveau de l'année
dernière et on a aussi le marché de
l'immobilier sur lesquels les prix sont
actuellement extrêmement élevé donc oui
effectivement on peut se poser la
question de savoir si on n'est pas face
à de multiples bulles qui sont en train
de se constituer dans l'économie alors
j'aime prenons les choses dans l'ordre
on va commencer par le marché du bitcoin
que se passe-t-il pourquoi a déjà une
telle flambée alors le marché de bitcoin
il faut le rappeler
on est parti de rien il ya évidemment
quelques années on était autour de 5000
$ l'année dernière où à la fin de
l'hiver 2019 2020 et puis maintenant on
est monté à quasiment cinquante huit
mille dollars à un moment donné avant de
connaître une chute qu'est ce que ça
veut dire
eh bien ça veut dire deux choses 1 le
bitcoin est devenu un actif un actif
comme les autres s'est pas réellement
une monnaie mais c'est un actif dans
lequel les gens cherchent à placer leur
argent
le deuxième point et c'est encore plus
important c'est un actif qui est
excessivement spéculatifs on le voit
bien
on voit bien que aujourd'hui les courts
du bitkom sont particulièrement
erratique
donc oui on est là sur un phénomène de
très grandes spéculations alors les
cours de la bourse
eux ne montre-t-il pas une évolution
comparable
oui oui c'était fanni tout à fait on est
en fait en présence de la même situation
alors on pourrait penser que la bourse
allez refléter
d'abord la crise sanitaire que nous
connaissons avec refléter aussi le fait
que l'économie reste aujourd'hui
embourbé dans les conséquences de cette
crise sanitaire que nous ne sortirons de
cette crise au mieux qu'en 2022 pas du
tout après avoir digéré en deux trois
semaines
le choc de la crise sanitaire il y a un
an nous avons continué à monter c'est à
dire que nous avons vu les cours de la
bourse
continuer à monter et aujourd'hui si on
prend le dow jones à wall street
on est sur des niveaux qui sont
historiquement élevé on a bien le
sentiment qu'il y ait une déconnexion
entre les mouvements des marchés
financiers les mouvements de la bourse
et l'économie réelle
et ça c'est un signal extrêmement clair
d'une situation spéculative et vous nous
dit jacques que l'immobilier est
également concernée
oui tout à fait alors pas partout si on
prend le cas en france on voit que cela
concerne essentiellement l'île de france
la région parisienne la région lyonnaise
mais ce que l'on aussi c'est que les
cours montent de manière tout à fait
considérable que ces cours ont continué
de monter avec le début de la pandémie
bon ils ont tellement monté qu'à partir
d'un moment ils ont commencé à se tasser
et abc mais de manière extrêmement léger
qu'est ce que ça signifie là encore on
voit bien il y a beaucoup d'argent qui
cherchent à s'investir il va s'investir
essentiellement dans l'immobilier et sur
des régions où les prix sont déjà très
élevés
c'est typiquement la caractéristique
d'un marché spéculatif
alors jacques quelle est la cause de
cette désordre première cause il faut le
dire ce sont les politiques des banques
centrales prenons le cas de la banque
centrale européenne ce qui est très net
c'est que la banque centrale européenne
qui maintenait l'année dernière à dijon
jusqu'au début de la pandémie qui
maintenait de toutes les manières une
politique très accommodante
et bien elle a littéralement ouvert les
vannes depuis la fin du mois de février
le début du mois de mars 2020 dont il ya
exactement un an
et qu'est ce qu'on voit on voit que de
ce fait la logique de deux montées de la
masse monétaire devient absolument
insensé on était parti un de taux qui
était de l'ordre de 5 à 6%
on se retrouve aujourd'hui à des taux
qui sont de l'ordre de 13% et qu'est ce
qu'il ya derrière il ya derrière le fait
que la bce a maintenu il ya même
augmenter son programme de rachat des
titres qui ciblait les banques et
surtout que la bce a mis sur pied un
programme spécial ce qui s'appelle le pe
pp le programme d'urgence de réaction
face à la pandémie ou là la bce achète
des centaines et des centaines de
milliards d'euros de titres aux états
donc on voit bien là encore on est face
à une politique qui est devenu
extrêmement laxiste extrêmement je
dirais pro activité de la part de la
banque centrale européenne alors jacques
est ce que cela est propre à l'europe
non non non non il faut le dire ce sont
des politiques que l'on retrouve dans
l'ensemble des banques centrales
qu'il s'agisse de la banque d'angleterre
de la banque du japon
et si on regarde la réserve fédérale eh
bien on va voir que la cour était est à
peu près la même
on avait une augmentation qui était
importante mais qui restait quand même
relativement modérée jusqu'au mois de
février 2020 et depuis le mois de
février 2020 bien là encore on voit une
augmentation extrêmement rapide de la
masse monétaire qui correspond tout
simplement au près et au refinancement
des banques
que fait très largement la réserve
fédérale
donc là aussi on voit que l'on est en
présence de politique générale de la
part des banques centrales qui consiste
à
j'écoutais massivement de la monnaie
dans l'économie alors vous avez aussi
parlé de bulles mais ne va-t-il pas y
avoir
jacques de l'inflation également ça
serait d'une certaine manière la réponse
traditionnelle
sauf que ce que l'on oublie c'est que
pour qu'une création monétaire à ce
niveau là puisse provoquer de
l'inflation
encore faudrait-il que nos économies
soit si ce n'est au plein emploi mais
soit disons dans des situations qui soit
relativement proche du plein emploi
ce n'est pas du tout le cas en réalité
nous sommes aujourd'hui avec des
situations où les niveaux d'activité des
économies restent relativement faibles
et vont rester faible encore pour les 2
3 ans qui viennent
donc ce qui veut dire que le risque
d'inflation en terre je dirais et des
housses de la hausse des prix à la
consommation n'est pas le risque
principal ce risque sera au pire très
modéré par contre ce que cela veut dire
c'est que on a une masse d'argent qui
cherche aujourd'hui à s'investir
évidemment il y a un problème parce que
les taux d'intérêt étant très bas que ce
soit en europe ou aux états unis
et bien cet argent cherche désespérément
des marchés sur lesquels ils pourraient
s'investir et un démarche est possible
eh bien ce sont ces marchés un petit peu
exotiques comme le marché du bitcoin
comme la bourse évidemment qui est moins
exotique qui est qui est plus
traditionnel ou encore comme
l'immobilier
alors en conclut jean-jacques maintenant
un système volatilité toujours plus
forte ces actifs oui oui c'est
effectivement un des risques auxquels on
peut être confrontés
on peut avoir avec la création de ce
type de bulles une situation où d'un
marché à l'autre on aurait des
phénomènes de contamination ce que l'on
voit aujourd'hui sur le bitcoin pourrait
finir par contaminer d'autres marchés
comme les bourses par exemple et qu'est
ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire que en
réalité nous sommes dans une situation
où les marchés
financier les marchés d'actifs son passé
moi l'expression sous stéroïdes
ils sont dopés par la politique des
banques centrales
mais inversement les banques centrales
elles mêmes sont devenues dépendantes
des marchés financiers et sont donc
d'une certaine manière
contraint de continuer à les alimenter
personne ne veut prendre le risque de
provoquer aujourd'hui une crise majeure
sur quelques marchés d'actifs que ce
soit merci jacques en tout cas pour
cette envie de tempête annoncé au moins
on sera prévenus merci à vous et c'est
la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain point complet sur
l'actualité dans quelques minutes avec
pierre qui sévit hivernaux
[Musique]
depuis des décennies il s'est imposé
comme la devise incontournable dans le
commerce international le dollar peut-il
être détrôné détrôner pas encore c'est
pas quelque chose d'à ce faire en lice
jo ce que le fait des chinois qu'ils
veulent des de l'arizona j parce que le
dollar à des folies qui viennent de
washington
ce qu'ont dit les chinois ben si ça vous
fait rien on va régler nos problèmes de
liquidité entre asiatiques et on va se
débarrasser des états unis aujourd'hui
les instruments sont en place pour
pouvoir se passer les transactions en
dollars
faut pas avoir fait de longues études
pour savoir si la masse monétaire double
aux états unis et des changements en
chine va probablement dans les années
qui viennent la monnaie chinoise a monté
vis-à-vis de la monnaie américaine et
donc grosso modo il me semble que s'il
était un jeune homme je suivrai le
conseil de barral est jeune homme pour
une fois je paraphrase ray monsieur
macron c'est en marche
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la peuplent
sap est une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'ya
pas une thérapie ressort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça